[Applaudissements]
sciences bonjour et bienvenue cette
semaine pour ce four accord anatomiques
en compagnie de michel bonjour michel
michel pour fait tu m'appelles michèle
montech anatomique bidon un crâne de
chien qu'on veut nous faire passer pour
un extraterrestre à elle m'échappe
le cinéma c'est l'art de l'illusion de
la tromperie et autant ya des fois où
les effets fonctionne comme dans les
derniers qu'il comble où ces crânes de
gorille géant ressemble bel et bien à
ceux qu'ils sont censés être bon en même
temps c'était pas dur il suffisait de
prendre un vrai crâne de gorilles et de
le refaire en plus gros autant il ya des
fois où on nous prend vraiment pour des
jambons en voici quelques exemples
provenant de vos films préférés qui j'en
suis sûr ne manquons pas de bien voulait
gâcher alertera jeunes si vous n'aimez
pas les critiques scientifiques de films
ou si vous ne voulez pas vous faire
spoiler
passez votre chemin on ne le répétera
pas commençons par les chouchous du
grand écran en ce moment j'ai nommé le
marvel cinématiques universe
dans cet extrait des gardiens de la
galaxie volume 2 on a le droit à une
orgie de nonos du porno pour anatomiste
coup il s'agit ni plus ni moins que des
cadavres des différents enfants du père
de peter qu'il est censé avoir eu avec
des races aliens provenant de tout
l'univers nuit de tout l'univers du coup
la déception est grande quand on réalise
que c'est surtout de l'humain à part ces
deux crânes la dont l'un correspond à un
lyon à peine des formes et pour avoir
l'air moins terrestre et l'autre un chat
qui mis au premier plan paraît beaucoup
plus gros qu'il ne l'est en réalité
tu es resté s'enfonçant humain ça fait
déchanter forcément sur le plein sinon
on a droit à un ami ou à deux têtes
un grand classique des musée d'anatomie
ainsi qu'un autre crâne humain je vous
invite à vous en rappelez et à ce truc
bizarre dont on peut voir la mâchoire on
retrouve le même truc bizarre sur le
plan suivant pour se rendre compte avec
horreur que sa bouche n'a pas de troncs
havrais les plaines dos oui la face de
ce crâne est en fait que l'arrière d'un
crâne qu'on a retourné regardez il n'ya
pas dieu et on voit les condyles
occipitaux qui forment l'articulation
avec la première vertèbre du cou
oh mais oui et là c'est pas le trou pour
la moelle épinière qui est transformé en
est là ici c'est le foramen magnum c'est
bien lui
et maintenant que vous êtes familier
avec la sienne en question vous avez
certainement repéré le crâne humain et
la nuit à deux têtes du plan précédent
on se paye pas nos tronches du tout pour
ce qui est des extraterrestres en carton
les gardiens de la galaxie n'en n'était
pas à leur coup d'essai puisque tout
début du premier film nous
ils ont admiré ce squelette d'alien qui
n'est ni plus ni moins qu'un crâne de
cheval monté sur ce que l'étude et ouais
les gars votre squelette en mousse on
l'a complètement grillé
bon on tape sur marvel mais le dc
universe ce n'est pas en reste dans la
trop de man of steel le détenteur de la
mémoire génétique de tout criton de
codex n'est autre qu'un joli petit crâne
fossilisé
là on va jouer un petit jeu lequel de
ces crânes et le véritable codex
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous avez trouvé facile mais non
c'était la réponse est bien sûr bon la
seule différence avec les autres ce sont
les gras durs jaune mais pour le reste
ça a tout l'air d'un crâne possible je
me mine et du coup est ce que ça veut
dire que les kryptoniens ont un ancêtre
en commun avec les grands singes
terrestre comme nous est ce que c'est un
chimpanzé qu'on a envoyé dans l'espace
et qui est l'ancêtre de superman le dc
universe ce n'est pas le seul à avoir
toujours en matière d'évolution dans
ghost in the shell l'animé original bien
sûr voilà la bataille avec le temps que
se déroule dans un environnement de
musée on y retrouve les ichtyosaures et
aussi cette petite référence à l'un des
premiers arbres phylogénétiques dessinés
par elle et qu'elle est où l'homme se
situe tout seul mais sauf que quand on
repasse le tour au ralenti on se rend
bien vite compte que les dessinateurs
n'avait pas une idée très nette de ce
qu'il faisait alors de base en eau ont
trop mal à petit russe un poisson-chat
électrique ainsi panne série dé la
famille des esturgeons si du reform la
famille des poissons chats donc
m'adapter russe n'est plus un poisson
chat c'est ça l'optimus un poisson de la
famille des bouts droits
leschi mairie d'hénin famille des
chimères des poissons cartilagineux des
grands fonds de proches dirait bien géré
les congrès d une famille d'anguilles
mais quelle idée encore des poissons
chats décidément c'est surtout du
poisson dans cette file au génie les
signes dont il est la famille des
poissons les arts les envies des idées
la famille des anguilles nu l idée est
ce qu'ils ont voulu écrire mur et une
idée la famille des murènes peut-être
mais il ya une idée en tout cas ça
n'existe pas et qu'on privé et là c'est
pas à combler dès qu'ils voulaient dire
et je pense pas puisqu'ils ont déjà dit
plus haut une grille d abba peut-être
que si il était visiblement en panne
d'imagination car voilà les signaux
reform l'ati mejia a enfin un poisson la
lueur charnue le fameux c'est la conte
on se rapproche un petit peu de l'homme
c'est pas trop tôt à anne un énorme
voilà les poissons cartilagineux radja
le genre auquel appartient la raie manta
et pris 6 le poisson si tous les deux de
proches parents des requins et
finalement culminant tout en haut de
l'arbre évolutif des poissons
cartilagineux et des poissons chats
l'homme
et pour ceux qui espéraient que ce soit
le mot charpente est sur la droite non
c'est en fait le mot chimères idée
encore on peut pas être des génies dans
tous les domaines je ne fais pas dire
car maintenant on s'attaque à un autre
film de génie le seigneur des anneaux le
retour du roi
une grande réussite oui n'est pas sous
tous les aspects non mais c'est bon là
je te vois venir tu vas nous faire
remarquer que les squelettes qui
dégringole dans la caverne
en fait c'est que des crânes et que du
coup c'est des têtes qui se sont baladés
comme ça sans corps qui sont venus se
promener mais non je t'ai anticipé ce
sont des trophées en fait ils ont été
décapités c'est ça les intrus et on n'a
gardé que leur tête à jeter eu non en
fait ce dont je voulais parler c'était
de la scène de l'antre de l'araignée
géante chez l'homme
golo nous explique que l'araignée n'a
rien d'autre à manger que des sorts que
trace et que du coup un hobby bien
trébuchant jamais et nous mitonne le
nabot regarder ce qu'on trouve dans sa
caverne à bahamas alors un babouin et un
crâne devant chez elle c'est sûr que
pour une pauvre bête censé mourir de
faim elle a tout l'air d'avoir une
nourriture variée
ouais juste quelques centaines de kilos
de viande fraîche quoi gollum c'est un
mytho j'ai toujours dit et le
fantastique n'est pas en reste dans le
générique du gone sylla de 2014
on nous suggère très subtilement que
godzilla est un dinosaure ou du moins à
reptiles géants du mésozoïque mes cd
saad car on peut voir le squelette des
deux ya un moment et il n'a rien à voir
avec celui d'un reptile godzilla est un
mammifère
regardez godzilla la colonne vertébrale
divisé en une région thoracique avec de
longues côtes et une région lombaire
chant côte
c'est typique des manies faire ça des
crocodiles les régimes arabes les
dinosaures n'ont pas de région lombaire
à leur colonne vertébrale et vous allez
dire qu'on exagère godzilla il a quand
même pas la tête d'un mammifère est
belle si justement chez les vertébrés
terrestres
on y 5,5 forme de crâne d'un acccident
ont un crâne s'enfonce temporal les
synopsis ont une fausse temporal basse à
l'opposé les agapes s'ils font une pause
temporal haute et enfin les dioxydes on
les deux basses et hautes et les
archosaures à granby apside avec en plus
une fosse à l'avant de leur [ __ ] et sur
la mandibule ce qu'on appelle
communément les reptiles ont un crâne
soit anna psy comme les tortues ou
dioxyde comme les arts modernes les 10
or eux ont un crâne archosaures comme
les crocodiles tandis que les reptiles
marins et un crâne euripide et godzilla
et bago dit leila bagot dit là il a rien
de tout ça en fait
eh bien oui parce qu'il a un crâne d'une
abside à une seule fausse temporal
limité par une belle arcade légal comme
les mammifères le pourtant mozilla il a
bien des écailles
ah ça oui et des mammifères à écailles
j'en connais par contre des reptiles à
vertèbres lombaires je n'en connais pas
à part peut-être les rétines mamani
ainsi nous donc mais après cela des
reptiles c'est un peu fort de café touba
il faut se rendre à l'évidence godzilla
est à fond gaulle un bipède géant
radioactive cracheurs de feu
ah bah tiens puisqu'une dark vador s'en
mêle retournons un peu à la sf
vous connaissez peut-être l'exil dit a
bien de la série star trek enterprise
il s'agit d'une ancienne race d'alien à
forme d'oiseau qui a disparu il ya très
très longtemps
oui et tout ce qui nous reste c'est ce
crâne
non michel ça c'est une girafe alors
d'une je m'appelle pas michel et de deux
ça c'est un crâne de xynthia bien même
que c'est eux qui le disent alors je
veux bien que l'absence d'un cif sur la
mâchoire supérieure si caractéristique
de tous les ruminants et pu faire penser
aux créateurs de la série que ce crâne
passerait pour un crâne d'oiseaux mais
non c'est définitivement de la girafe
on vous prend pour une buse là michel
bon d'accord de toute façon tout le
monde n'est pas très qui met par contre
tout le monde connaît star wars et si
vous connaissez déjà notre chaîne vous
savez que star wars et la paléontologie
sont franchement très potes vous ne nous
croyez pas alors voici pour vos yeux
ébahis le mammouth de solo star wars
story il est bien reconnaissable à la
courbure de ses dépenses
et voici une mâchoire de mammouth dans
l'empiré contre attaque ou parodient
mammouth et dans la neige sur la planète
de glace haute
sinon il s'agit peut-être de celle d'un
éléphant et la retour au premier épisode
de la trilogie avec 6 p o qui croise le
squelette d'un très longue animal le
crâne est complètement inventée par
contre la colonne vertébrale
elle porte un signe distinctif oui les
arcs neuro ou épineux râle si vous
préférez sont dédoublés et ça c'est
typique du dinosaure diplodocus et des
autres diplômes aussi des arcs neural
dédoubler s'est littéralement ce que
veut dire diplodocus
last but not least voici le boss final
des collectionneurs de crâne du cinéma
le predator à le prédateur si puissant
et redoutable qu'il parvient à tailler
en pièces des xénomorphes à son sushi
est pourtant le premier à avoir visité
la terre s'est fait maîtrisé par choisi
mis en pl ace par un misérable humain
c'est y pas la honte intergalactique ça
ouais mais attend ses choix dit quand
même
ouais mais moi j'ai une autre théorie
moi je pense que les predator ils ont
fort envoyé à guerriers d'élite a choisi
mais plutôt un bon gros branquignols du
predator au rabais s'ils te fait dire ça
le prédateur du premier film se balade
avec quelques trophées de chasse des
souvenirs en pendentif quoi elle ça fout
les jetons oui au premier abord oui mais
quand on y regarde de près ça c'est un
chat ça c'est un autre chat ça c'est un
rond
leur typique d'amérique qu'on appelle un
chien de prairie et ça c'est mon petit
chouchou
il s'agit d'un poisson qu'on ne
rencontre qu'en amérique et qui
s'appelle une l'épisode théo gare pic
ah oui bah oui avoir flingué de chahains
rongeurs et de la poiscaille ya pas de
quoi attraper la chercher à sa non c'est
pas la gloire
pas étonnant que je lui ai mis la misère
cet épisode est terminé merci de l'avoir
suivi si vous avez apprécié et que vous
voulez un autre épisode comme ça laissez
des commentaires au mozambique en les
squelettes a identifié dans vos films
préférés et surtout partager la vidéo
pour nous montrer que ça vous plaît et
la semaine prochaine michel on revient
et cette fois j'aurai du lourd du très
très lourd parce qu'une prochaine
michel non mais c'est pas bientôt fini
c'est quoi
[Musique]